[Musique]
salut à tous depuis début 2010 8 sur les
questions européennes et internationales
vous avez certainement entendu des
journalistes ou des commentateurs parler
de démocratie libérale ou du libéralisme
pour désigner des régimes initialement
démocratique tendance à devenir
autoritaire sous ces termes à se cache
toute une batterie de concept utile pour
penser la démocratie et ses évolutions
patrick concept que malheureusement les
commentateurs ne se donne pas la peine
d'expliquer alors la démocratie libérale
c'est quoi se terminer à la fin des
années 90 sous la plume de fareed
zakaria un journaliste indo américain
pour tenter d'expliquer un phénomène
alors nouveau alors que depuis plus d'un
siècle le terme de démocratie était
attaché aux démocraties occidentales
dites libérales qui repose sur des
élections libres et sur le respect des
droits individuels des pays pratiquant
les élections mais peu soucieux des
droits et libertés des citoyens
apparaissait alors zakaria noter aussi
un paradoxe de ces nouvelles démocraties
elle était parfois plus intolérantes au
niveau religieux et ethniques que les
dictatures laïques qu'elle remplaçait à
l'époque près de chez nous on peut
penser à l'ex yougoslavie
un pays communiste composé de cinq
républiques ethniques qui se sont
déchirées après la chute des régimes
soviétiques au point de basculer dans la
guerre civile
aujourd'hui on peut penser aux pays
ayant connu les printemps arabes ou plus
discrètement à nombre de pays où les
différences ethniques entraîne des votes
communautaire comme l'un d'eux natale de
zakaria
bref on s'aperçoit au cours des années
90 que démocratie et respect des droits
et libertés ne sont pas forcément liés
et que les démocraties occidentales sont
peut-être des exceptions pour comprendre
ce phénomène
zakaria la caractériser les démocraties
libérales occidentales modèles
théoriques pour ces nouvelles
démocraties comme étant constitué de
deux éléments
d'abord la démocratie c'est à dire un
système basé sur des élections libres
avec un pluralisme de candidats et de
programmes politiques et ensuite de ce
qu'il appelle le libéralisme
constitutionnel à savoir des éléments
qui garantisse les libertés
individuelles de type libéral liberté de
parole et de réunion
liberté de conscience droit de propriété
égalité en droits des citoyens
séparation et limitation des pouvoirs
état de droit mais l'un des deux
éléments peut manquer on peut avoir une
démocratie libérale ou une autocratie
libéral
cette démocratie libérale c'est
typiquement ce que l'on voit dans les
nouvelles démocraties des années 90 mais
cela permet aussi de décrire un
phénomène nouveau du 21e siècle celui de
démocratie libérale bien installés qui
commence à se déliter avec une érosion
de l'état de droit
on parle souvent de la pologne ou de la
hongrie comme étant dans ce cas hors ban
le président de cette dernière se
revendiquant lui même d'une politique
libérale
quant aux autocraties libéral ce sont
des pays qui protègent les droits
individuels mais ça soit sur la
démocratie selon zakaria c'est la forme
typique des régimes européens du 19e
siècle un état de droit où la démocratie
est limité notamment par le droit de
vote censitaire masculin dans la seconde
moitié du 20e siècle
ce profil est aussi celui de pays d'asie
du sud est comme taiwan ou la corée du
sud qui étaient des dictatures
économiquement libéral avant de se
transformer en démocratie ou encore de
singapour actuellement cela fait dire à
zakaria que là où la démocratie libérale
fonctionne le libéralisme
constitutionnel précède la démocratie et
donc tenté d'imposer la démocratie par
la force un état sans libéralisme
politique et peut-être une mauvaise idée
voilà donc la théorie qui se cache
derrière les termes de démocratie
libérale et du libéralisme
maintenant passons aux travaux pratiques
car cette grille d'analysé peut nous
permettre de comprendre d'autres
phénomènes que l'érosion de l'état de
droit
elle peut par exemple nous permettre
d'avoir une critique intéressante de
l'union européenne
mais là ce ne sera que mon avis
tout d'abord l'union européenne peut
être vu comme une autocratie
elle a été créée par en eau par une
suite de processus décidé d'en haut sans
en référer aux citoyens des pays
concernés
le premier vote populaire eu lieu en
1979 pour élire un parlement européen
sans que l'on ait au préalable demander
aux citoyens s'ils voulaient seulement
de ce parlement parlement croupion
d'ailleurs puisqu'il ne rédige pas les
lois et se contente de voter celle que
lui propose la commission et le conseil
de l'union européenne
deux institutions non élus la commission
détient le vrai pouvoir et peut faire
passer sa volonté aux états sans passer
par ce parlement fantoche via ses
directives ajoutons à cela que la
démocratie populaire européenne est un
alibi
quand les citoyens ratifie le traité de
maastricht en 1992 l'union européenne
reconnaît le vote
mais quand en 2005 deux pays par
référendum refuse la ratification du
traité constitutionnel européen l'union
s'assoit sur leur décision crée le
traité de lisbonne une constitution
light qu'elle fait voté par les
parlements nationaux avec ou contre la
vie démocratique
la marche de l'union est à peu près la
même à côté de cela le à libéral la bce
la banque centrale européenne qui a créé
est indépendante elle est mandatée pour
contenir l'inflation ce qui n'est pas
une politique économiquement neutre mais
fait partie de la doctrine monétaire
libéral le libéralisme économique est
aussi au centre des décisions de la
commission qui ordonne depuis des années
aux états membres d'ouvrir des secteurs
comme l'énergie et le transport
ferroviaire au privé par pure idéologie
bref les outils de zakaria permettent de
multiples analyses et à mon avis
appliqué à l'union européenne
ils produisent une critique qui permet
de sortir du clivage pro-européen
progressiste contre souverainistes et
nationalistes que veut imposer macron
est à mon sens les eurosceptiques et
souverainistes de gauche et de droite
devrait s'emparer de cette grille de
lecture qui permet d'inverser la charge
négative en collant l'étiquette
antidémocrates au projet européen
c'est courant anti union européenne ont
d'autant plus intérêt à s'approprier ces
concepts qu'en france certains
journalistes j'ai l'impression
commencent à utiliser le terme libéral
en remplacement de solides populisme
comme injures et il serait dommage que
ce genre de concept utile pour penser
finisse comme de simples les insultes
bref j'espère que cette vidéo sur la
démocratie libérale vous aura intéressé
et vous aura appris des choses si c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas à la partager
et moi je vous dis à la prochaine
[Musique]